for a lot of people mortality is um
one of the
very unfortunate versions of suffering
which is that the ride ends
in this realm whatever whatever it is
what do you think of mortality is it
something you
think about
is this something you fear um what do
you think happens i don't after we fury
i don't fear it uh
first of all i would say when i was in
high school i think my father actually
encouraged me to read this book
i read ernest becker's denial of death
which i found and still find to be one
of the most profound works i've ever
come across
and he convinced me that a lot of what
our society is about are
ways that we avoid encountering our own
mortality
our physicality i mean one among the
points he makes and i'm i'm not
quoting him at all directly it's like
why does everything about our physical
body make us so uncomfortable everything
that comes out of you other than tears
is either mildly or very disgusting why
why does that have to be why are sex and
eating and all the things that are
physical surrounded with so much
symbolism i mean what are table matters
really they're like we're not eating
like animals because we're not eating
like animals and sex obviously has more
symbolism around it than anything
and his answer is anything that reminds
you that you're a physical body because
that's what dies your body dies it
decays it dies it gets eaten by worms
that you don't want to think about so
you deny it
um i think that part of religion is a
confrontation with your own mortality
but also a certain transcendence of it
because the idea is something about you
is eternal
what exactly i don't know
um
and you asked what do i think happens
after we die
so
i don't know any better than anyone else
does but i will i'll say two things
about it um
one is
that every image of what it's like
is foolish like
mark twain has i think in letters from
earth he says we're going to lie on
green fields and listen to harp music
which you wouldn't want to do for five
minutes while you're alive but you think
you'll be happy for the rest of eternity
doing it after you die
so i don't know this world was a
surprise so why shouldn't the next world
be a surprise i have no idea
but i really like this parable that's
told by a guy um
in uh
in a book on death in mourning by a
rabbi in a book on death and morning
about twins in a womb
he says and
one of them believes that there's a life
outside and the other one doesn't
he says
the one who doesn't says look this is
the only world we've ever seen the only
world we've ever known why do you think
there's something out there he says now
imagine the one who believes is born
back in the womb his brother is mourning
a death but outside everybody's
celebrating a birth he said and that's
what it's like when you die
and i love that image
the yeah the grass is always greener
it's the new the new step but the
eternity thing is an interesting one i i
it's yet another concept that i feel
humans are
fully inequipped to comprehend
um is eternity fundamental somehow to
all these discussions i think it is well
partly because god is supposed to be
eternal
and and therefore it moves the mind in
that direction even though it is
completely unfathomable
um you know because sometimes i would
say eternity you said on a green field
sometimes a moment
like a truly joyful moment right feels
like an eternity the intensity of it i
maybe eternity is more about stopping
time versus extending time indefinitely
and it's something that we just totally
can't comprehend
us silly humans all i would say is um
the at the older you get the more you're
struck by the fact that time does not
freeze
you know people will sometimes say to me
you
you haven't aged a day and then i'll
look at an old picture of myself
and i'll say
that was very kind of you but that's not
true it's not true um so yeah i mean i
love the idea of you know we turn to
seeing eternity in a grain of sand was
how blake put it i love that notion but
when you talk about life after death
i really i think that in some ways my
fundamental faith isn't is in
human beings that this doesn't all
disappear that there's something about
people
that transcends this world
you